now I want to start from the beginning
with you yes we got a lot of things I
want to get to obviously Florida stuff
going DeSantis announcing Trump roasting
him everything but I think your life
experiences have have informed your
perspective in a way that a lot of other
people in the media field uh maybe do
not know or can't relate to or they just
don't have these life experiences so
bring me back to the beginning Iran
born
Christian
Assyrian and Armenian Assyrian and
Armenian okay
very briefly what is a Syrian Assyrian
is Babylonian they're the first
Christians first warriors
uh you know them and Armenians always
debate on who was the first Christian if
you read the Bible you see Assyrians all
the time Aramaic so I speak Aramaic so
Passion of the Christ you speak Arabic I
speak Arabia the movie passing the
crisis we understand what they were
saying wow nobody else well I mean
except for seven of us
wait you grew
the language the Buzz ran yes
yes is it different in Aramaic than it
is in English I'll give you our numbers
yes they got to make it about themselves
every single time we were having a nice
moment over here with the Christians the
Jews come in and anyway uh okay so so
you're in Iran
shuffles
what is happening in Iran during the the
reign of the Shah
so the Shah goes from being this 21 year
old guy comes in his father is this
powerful man who is kicked out a couple
times he has feared he is hated he is
you know respected he's a guy that
raises a son in a way that they're not
that close it's like you know it's the
father it's the shot the king and the
son has to go do all this different work
he spoke seven different languages
a smart guy he could do interviews in
literally seven different languages he
comes in he changes the game
was a guy that a lot of the he would be
the modern day Bernie Sanders so they
wanted mosader to be the president he
was going to give the oil money back to
the people all this stuff and then with
the help of CIA you'll read this in many
different places the Shah ends up coming
in uh he becomes the king and then
changes everything in Iran you know
education improves women Freedom voice
they can become lawyers you know there
was a entertainment aspect to it Frank
Sinatra all these guys used to go to
Iran it was
top three richest like the wealthiest of
the wealthiest in the 70s and the late
60s you would go to Iran Burma and Cuba
was it like Dubai I'm trying to imagine
it was like Dubai I mean listen uh
Elizabeth Taylor was dating the
Ambassador zahidi they were together so
she would go to visit them Elizabeth and
she dated everybody but she was also
dating at the time and then all of a
sudden you know Khomeini from France is
sending these tapes before there was
YouTube there were these tapes that
would go viral so guys were sitting
there recording these tapes and giving
it away to people and how many is
talking about how bad it is what's going
on in Iran and how he put this party
together the 2500 Year party in Iran and
that was the end of it I cannot believe
you spend this much money look how much
money you're spending on the lavish
party he invited everybody to Iran if
you ever see the pictures of this party
it's insane what he did with the party
and then eventually you know Jimmy
Carter comes in
December 31st 1977 there's a toast Jimmy
Carter says this is a very important
partner to us the moment he imagine New
Year's you can be anywhere in the world
he's in Iran okay
he leaves
next thing you know gradually Revolution
starts one by one by one and then
eventually nine million people revolted
after this event that took place uh
Cinema wrecks fire in a city called is
like a bunch of provinces it's a it was
a beautiful place this movie theater 400
people are in there they lock the doors
from both ends they turn the place on
fire people die the police station is
right across the street Khomeini says it
was uh Shahs people that did a Savage
savakas like the CIA MI6
and the shot says we didn't do anything
here why would we kill 400 people well
many shots people like how many people
did this anyways the people believe
khomeini's camp and they said Shaw was
behind us
long story short I'm born October 1878
which is at the peak of Cinema Rick's
fire my mother wonder you know we're
going to the hospital curfew 10 o'clock
they have to be escorted I go to the
hospital I'm born uh three months later
Shaw's out
and then Iran falls in the rest is
history what happens to Christians in
Iran at this time it's a scary time to
be a Christian it's a scary time to be
Baha'i it is a scary time to be pro-shaw
it is a scary time to be uh any military
leader part of shots Camp they were you
know that was connected to the Shah no
he was a fan of the Shah my dad was a
regular guy we don't come from a a lot
of money uh but my dad they were
imperialist and my mother they were
Communists my mother's family there were
strong Communists and at the time
and so they couldn't stand the shaw you
know she they were happy the shaw fell
so I'm in the middle of my mom he thinks
rich people are greedy my dad thinks
poor people are lazy and I'm seeing this
is the big going back and it's the best
debate ever
welcome to America
but let me tell you that my mother
taught me the paranoia site you know and
I think you need that in business I
think you need that in life I think you
need that what do you mean by that the
parent paranoia where you gotta you know
only the paranoid survive Andy Grove the
Hungarian entrepreneur who ran Intel
he's the Godfather of Silicon Valley
where everybody admired this guy he
wrote a book in the 80s and maybe the
early 90s called only the paranoid
survive in the game of business
if you're not paranoid boom somebody
takes you out same in the military
same in business you need a little bit
of that so growing up in this kind of a
climate in Iran you're always like are
you Christian why do you ask instead of
yes I am you know hey what nationality
are you instead of giving the answers
like what's the motive behind the
question because you're a little bit
paranoid so
that kind of helps I know people may
look at it and say was that really a
good thing or a bad thing I think it's a
very good thing okay so then from Iran
yeah you guys flee yes go to Germany yes
refugee camp yep are you worried about
going to like a camp in Germany given
the history yeah let me put it to this
way man I mean for us in Iran how many
died this is like he died June 2nd I
want to save 89 uh June 2nd or 3rd he
dies I'm in school parents can't find me
you know there is no Uber tax this that
riots protesting everywhere I'm trying
to find my mom I'm 10 years old and we
finally do they take us home we get to
the house my mom and dad have this
exchange together we got to get the hell
out of here we're not staying here if he
stays here he's got to serve the
military here boom six weeks later we go
to Germany refugee camp we're on the
plane Lufthansa
and you hear the announcer saying you
know uh you're free to drink alcohol
we've officially crossed the border
everybody felt free because nobody
thought it was real until they say you
can drink out wow it's a very wild
moment yeah I will never forget that no
wow okay you land what's the refugee
camp in Germany like I mean listen man
it's not what you think it's just a
bunch of people that are trying to fight
for Freedom you know we're all from
Poland from Slovakia at the time
Yugoslavia family you know Anna Maria
drug you know the staff family over here
and we're all living together every that
would come they would drop off the food
you would go pick it up the Apple you
know juice all this stuff milk you would
bring it in we had a small little park
it was an Army base right next to us and
so we would go and look over the
building to see what the guys were
blowing up in the army base so
um
that's what it was like and you know
you'd go to school and they would look
at you you know you came to our country
and you're making it worse because there
was some you know a lot of things were
going on with the stabbing the fights
all this stuff so I'm a middle eastern
guy you automatically put that person
into you you can't blame the guys to be
thinking now because there was a lot of
that going on in Germany but it was It
was a
it was a different experience how do you
get to America
uh so we're there for about a year and a
half eventually we get the green card
and uh we get the call we're going and
it's November 28 1990. we land in New
York
uh I'm looking for uh Rocky I'm looking
forward Goonies I'm looking for Gremlins
if you remember gremlin's back in the
days where are these guys at I couldn't
find any of them eventually we got 12.
there's some gremlers out here
and then eventually we get to LA from
New York and you know now any idea why
La sorry well I mean yeah pay respect to
Mecca right which is Glendale
Granada Hills then Glendale and then we
stayed in Glendale for six years oh wow
everybody looks like this in Glendale
your parents plan the whole time was to
go to Glendale no no no not at all my my
dad wanted to stay but my dad also had a
sister in Chicago so he would always
come back and forth from Chicago in 84
he comes back he brings this tape with
the best 80s songs so when we came in
you're playing the 80s music it was sick
because every time I listened to 80s
I'll go back to that tape by the way
whoever picked the songs I'm still
trying to figure this out Calvin Harris
you know all this stuff he played was
great
um but yeah you know it's uh it was a
great experience okay growing up in LA
you feel probably a little bit more
comfortable I imagine because you're
growing up around a lot of people kind
of look like you shared experience I
think at this time there's a lot of
Persians that are moving into Beverly
Hills they also left out for the shop
well right so there's so now maybe you
don't feel as uh out of place
is that fair to say I felt at a place in
Germany I don't feel out of place in uh
no I'm saying absolutely you're right
okay you're in place in Glendale yeah
yeah absolutely the desire to be
American right to prove your
american-ness
does that happen when you're a kid
moving here you're seeing the movies and
you're like I want to take part in this
experiment does it happen when you're in
LA
I'm wondering because you go to the Air
Force and I've always thought that like
that is a way of proving that you're
willing to pay the price to be part of
this Amazing Experiment was that your
motivation so you know the the concept
the evolution of becoming a proud
American probably happened due to a few
different events one of them I would say
is as you age whatever your parents sold
you whatever your teacher sold you
whatever the pastors Uncle sold you then
you find the contradictions and the
arguments and you're like yeah I don't
know about that because in Iran you've
grown up in an environment where
everybody says mad bad um recall mad bad
on because death upon America and
they're flagellating their back and
you're like looking outside hearing
these ten thousand men screams like why
death upon America it's the evil empire
it's horrible let me tell you what they
do they're rewarding they're behind all
the wars and they do this and they're
okay maybe they're right maybe they're
not I don't know yet skeptical let me
find out for myself rich people are
greedy and all this other stuff and I'm
like wait a minute what are you talking
about the only way you become rich is to
other people around you also become rich
you can become rich by yourself most
people that build a company that grew up
they don't have 100 equity in the
company you have to share the equity
other people come in you have to have
jobs you have to recruit good people you
have to keep them you're about to lose
the guy you don't give them that race
he's going to go elsewhere you can't
become rich by yourself you're going to
need other people that's going to help
you out so contradictions then I join
the military I'm in the Army Hannaford's
Airborne Division it's September of 97.
we walk in the unit they say there's a
movie coming out it's about our units
as long as we can get it we watch a
movie I'm all in I love movies so we go
600 kids when I say kids 18 to 25. this
movie you're going to be the first to
see it before it's public because it's
about your unit you have to be proud
about this movie it's your unit it's the
badge it's I'm like okay great let's see
what this is
I'm so fired up about this movie that
I'm coming out saying you know what I'm
proud to be an American then we go to
one of the military ceremonies whether
it was Memorial day or fourth of July
and I'm looking at these 40 year old
generals toughest man in tears coming
down and have a look like this but
they're crying because they lost the
soldier and you know how they fought for
freedom and everybody was kicking it
hanging out they're not thinking about
the people that had the hard lives and
I'm interviewing these guys what was it
like what was he like who's your friend
who's this and he gradually like listen
man this is this is an incredible
country and then more and more and more
as you come up in a regular guy like
this
with a 4.6 GPA
1510 s 18.
you know all of a sudden you're like uh
man you can actually win here and then
gradually the levels to winning keeps
going and you're like you know what else
is possible here it's just like playing
a game I'm gonna play this game out and
see where it goes and then obviously
I can sell this is the greatest country
in the world comfortably
in many different ways results Freedom
you know what we've been able to produce
why so many people come here if we're a
restaurant it's a restaurant that's
always full everybody's in line trying
to get into this restaurant even when
we're busy even more people want to come
here legally illegally risk their lives
it doesn't matter everybody wants to
come here so now that doesn't guarantee
this place is going to stay this great
you know I'm having breakfast with a a a
very successful man in Hollywood and
we're going back and forth and the
question that becomes okay so now what
do we do I got four kids I got an 11
year old nine-year-old six-year-old
she's going to be seven tomorrow
and I got a two-year-old she'll be two
in a month
we have a great life but man can you
imagine it's kind of like well I made my
money I'm just going to chill I'm not
going to put myself out there because
I'm just kind of want to be invited to
all these parties I don't want to be not
invited to these parties I don't want to
be not part of these networks no we got
to do our part as well so I feel there's
a responsibility now to uh to bring it
from a different angle you know I'm
Middle Eastern so I can talk to white
black Hispanic Middle Eastern Asian
Christian atheists Rich poor middle
upper educated uneducated let's talk
let's hash it out let's see how many
things we have in common and what things
we disagree with give me your argument
why give me your argument why now let's
see what we got there so I think that's
that's kind of the concept of what
happened with the love for America I
wanted to ask you a question when you're
growing up you come here what's your
mentality about how you're going to take
advantage of being in America are you
looking at it like I'm gonna start my
own business I have capitalism at my
fingertips no I came here not trusting
America I came here like looking at the
white man like I've learned a lot about
you Mr white man I see you coming to
school in the BMW and we're coming in
and they used 79 Honda Accord hatchback
you know that only goes Drive doesn't go
reverse okay you're special you think
you're better than me right so that that
bit of animosity or kind of looking at
them uh funny that was there